We are used to have be people
with the conditions such as
congestive cardiac failures, hyper tension and liver failures
but now we usually nurse people with epigastric diseases
such as diarrhea
aseptic meningitis
usually streptococcus
mostly HIV related more than anything else now.
KwazZulu-Natal is one of the nine provinces in South Africa
and it really is the epicenter of
the co-epidemics in the country.
the rates
of TB infection here
and the rates of HIV are unprecedented throughout
the country. We know here at Edendale 60%
of women, pregnant women
test HIV positive so id we extrapolate that from that
we're looking at
mid to high 40%
so just under half
of the population is HIV
infected.
TB a couple decades ago
was on
the down swing, it was being controlled fairly
well
globally,
but with
HIV coming on the scene
you see TB rising exponentially because patients who are
HIV infected of course is much greater risk
of tuberculosis
so that's why TB is on the upswing
in the inner cities in the US
and definitely
in developing countries where
there's a high burden of HIV.
It's the number one killer
far and away
of patients who are HIV positive.
people
typically wait a very long time before they seek medical attention
so they present very where they are very very ill
and I think
we see a lot more people honestly die here
than we do in the US just because people
are so diseased and it presents so late
it receives so little treatment on the outside.
And I think one of the biggest differences
is we see HIV probably as HIV looked in the US
the late '80's early '90's before there were treatments
and you see all of the
the infections and ravages of the disease
that we're not really accustomed to seeing anymore
since therapy in countries that can afford it is so good.
The main thing that I've gained is just
a true personal experience
and understanding of it
you know, being here, during the epidemic
getting a sense of how things really are
you hear about it in the United States
but it's difficult to really
get a sense of it until you come here and you see
the burden that
there is in the hospitals
I mean 80-90% of patients here in the hospital
are HIV positive
and an incredible number of those have TB as well.
unfortunately it took XDR
to generate so much international
interest in the problems
now we have a lot of
of people thinking about
what better infection control measures,
better treatment mention measures, integrating
HIV and TB care, so these things are all essential
to relook at our protocols to find out
why are we failing the standard TB treatment
in the first place
that are leading to both the MDR and XDR epidemics.